Trump
[Music]
I'm not gonna lose you hear me now I'll
just cut you off completely
I'll inherit my Master's will you can't
defeat me no matter what you become I
Will Always Love You the Hokage is the
person who walks in front of everyone
and Bears all the pain
[Music]
why are you so obsessed with me
because we're friends
[Music]
my blood is boiling charge no despair
you can't escape how about this move I
win don't underestimate the will of fire
I'll settle this now is the hour of
judgment
this is
prepare yourself sweet dreams how about
this you'll be eaten alive
idiots Church
from here for history will be spun again
and so began their Journey
on a path with no end
with this power I will establish perfect
order what you describe is nothing more
than oppression through force and fear
my frail little brother no
do not wish to fight you elder brother